in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast we're going
back to back to back to back on some of
these things man sir hey you know what I
saw today actually before I came here
yeah
Bart sent me a little New York Times
post of [ __ ] Joe Rogan huh his
podcast originally was only on iTunes
which I didn't know about that until
recently because I always just iTunes
podcast but when I started getting the
podcast game I didn't realize that you
could put podcasts on Spotify and then
when I was looking for Joe Rogan stuff
on Spotify it's not there he hasn't had
his podcast on any other platform
besides iTunes exclusive feeling why I
don't know maybe he had a deal with them
but he was one of the oh geez in the
podcast right him Adam Carolla and a few
other people he just signed a hundred
million dollar deal and would Spotify to
exclusively put his podcast on the
Spotify platform in dollars a hundred
your Spotify listen you could offer me
twelve dollars and a and a [ __ ] pack
of Kit Kats and let's get it poppin
we'll keep it exclusively on Spotify but
they wanted his content so bad that they
offered him a hundred [ __ ] million
dollar my multi-year D I think it was
like I don't know how many years it is
it could be like three to four I could
look it up I don't really care - yeah
but for however X amount of years it
can't be more than three to four years
they offered him a hundred [ __ ]
million dollars to exclusively put his
podcast crazy on Spotify and the crazy
thing is it's like you got like who
would have ever thought Joe Rogan would
be you know one of the most popular
podcasts oh [ __ ] on [ __ ] Dave
Chappelle's deal Dave Chappelle was
offered what 50 million for two episodes
for you he's getting offered to do
something he already does for fun yeah
that he's already making probably like
what I don't know maybe like 10 million
on it anyways right just off of his own
ads alone yeah to do something he was
already doing and just putting it on one
platform which is Spotify that's the
only change you [ __ ] this guy so much
better than every [ __ ] aspect and he
has like a [ __ ] massively devastating
tech window kick
he was using my martial arts the same
[ __ ] person he has the cutest golden
retriever - you see that [ __ ] no I have
the Marshall Rogan is is his golden
retriever that's pretty dope knee
[ __ ] hard his gold metallic you did
he has the life man and well that and
now his owner has a hundred more million
dollars what do you need that extra 100
million for men was he needed X 100
million for hue
nobody's gonna complain with making an
extra hundred like hey just take your
podcast and put it to somewhere else
I'll give you a hundred million dollars
like that's it there's no strings
attached no strings attached just be
here for three or four years yeah but
you can't put out anywhere else but our
platform spot I'll give you 100 million
why the [ __ ] where do I sign where do I
[ __ ] suck his dick do I have to sign
create culture I'm actually a relative
to Andy from the fire documentary right
now do you have any idea what I would do
if I made a hundred million dollars yeah
I would still continue this podcast but
obviously a lot more crazier [ __ ] that's
for sure I mean look man a hundred
million dollars is obviously a life and
a game-changer to most people right but
I don't know if I would necessarily like
drastically change the way I live you
know you're [ __ ] out of your mind you
would address tably change the way you
live like in terms of like I wouldn't
all of a sudden just indulge myself in
extravagance you know what I mean I do
filet-o-fish everyday stiff industrial I
just take a bite and go away yeah I'm
not eating it because I have to I'm
eating it because you know I can't
different type of schedule [ __ ]
deliveries with every day I would have
somebody work out my body for me I just
lay down on the floor they move my legs
for me I don't know I I just don't think
that I would go to like the other end of
the spectrum in terms of like
extremities I don't think I would be
like oh yeah now I got a hundred million
dollars I'm gonna [ __ ] live life like
I wasn't living before you know dan
Bilzerian dude well that guy he was
living an extravagant life what what
does Dan Bilzerian do that is so much
[ __ ] money at that so that's that's a
question that has everybody has wondered
about you know cuz he said he made his
money from playing poker right but you
know point when poker players talk about
it they don't really know who rises
yeah they don't really recognize as a
dude that's been in the circuit you know
like really grinding away so like the
the rumor is is that his his dad was an
extremely wealthy guy and he just kind
of trickle-down effect you know the
Walter he's like poker and yeah use that
angle yeah exactly well exactly he like
was able to create a brand in a platform
around that about this playboy image and
then you know you get sponsorships from
that I don't know how true it is though
I think I don't think he's ever
confirmed because people have asked him
time and time again like where do you
get your wealth room and the only
concrete answer he gave was that from
playing poker like I became a
millionaire multi-millionaire from
playing poker but like I said the poker
players don't have a difference yeah
idea on it like how much money could
like if Phil Ivey was like yeah you know
I I know he I know Dan he's he's been in
the circuit you know grinding away and
he's won a lot of these tournaments but
like Phil maybe somebody who you won't
question like he's a multi-millionaire
from up being a great [ __ ] poker
player right but Dan is like nobody so
who are you yeah like I mean yeah I've
seen you in some tournaments but that's
not it yeah you're not like like a Road
Dogg see that makes me wonder too cuz
yeah
somebody told me - about Dan Bilzerian
he says that he doesn't you know cuz he
always has like these half-naked [ __ ]
with them all building in [ __ ]
yes I think somebody told me I think it
could have been a Joe Rogan podcast when
they were saying this but he was saying
that a the women that he has around him
he goes like the women that are out that
are around me like I they can't just be
around me for the money they don't like
me for me shut the [ __ ] up there's no
way all right yeah good Jilly you think
these [ __ ] half-naked [ __ ] are
around you because they're like this guy
right here yeah he's he's something
special dan Bilzerian new for all that
[ __ ] money your dumbest [ __ ] by the
way can we be best friends I talk this
[ __ ] but if I see you believe I mean
come on man time to be real you know
like you don't you don't have to [ __ ]
fake the phone you don't gotta front
like you got money you got a lifestyle
that these [ __ ] want to be a part of
you know even if it means bet for a very
short amount of time they want to
indulge themselves in that extravagant
lifestyle right it's like like you don't
give a [ __ ] about your personality
exactly were they [ __ ] sucking your
dick in like I like your mind the thing
kind of talking about Dan Bilzerian is
kind of reminding me of like the
Showtime Lakers and like what Magic
Johnson's life was like who's getting
his dick sucked by the show bro bro
no look like the Showtime Lakers the
team all right even like the Showtime
like the facade for some reason I picked
the cheerleading girls no no time during
the Showtime Laker I mean they were
Showtime on the court and off the court
it never stopped and I was watching like
a little documentary about it like it's
insane the amount that like the guy did
basic math on it and he would Magic
Johnson had a quote where he said he
felt like it was his responsibility to
service as many women as possible that's
like his god-given calling just like the
way he worded it really made it sound
like it was like a public duty that he
said this in public it was a public
question hilarious yeah I don't know why
I had AIDS
and that's another thing too is that how
great his PR team must be to where he
completely shifted the narrative like
this is a dude that had AIDS I mean it
never no he had HIV and never got to
AIDS right and because of his wealth and
because of his fame obviously he has
access to like new blood all the time
Johnson do ya experimental treatments
and like the best doctors and he was
basically able to UM he still has AIDS
but he's able to keep it he hasn't no
more no no he still has it it's just not
traceable amounts yeah you can't it's
they haven't found like a vaccine or a
cure to get rid of it oh I thought he
got it no that it was done no no he
still has to take his treatments and
what it does is it keeps it at bay and
so that sometimes it's not even
traceable in his blood you know but he's
still he still has I thought this will
beat aids completely no he didn't beat
it he just managed it so if I had an
open wound and he spit inside I got AIDS
this very possible but yeah you know
like I feel like a lot of the younger
generation might not even be aware that
Magic Johnson had eight you know what I
mean like they just see him as oh he was
an ex Laker a guy that's a overall
likable and charismatic guy who a lot of
players and people respect and it's just
that dude like ambassador of LA right he
he [ __ ] brings sports teams and like
elevates them and then he owns all these
businesses in LA right highly successful
businessman but then there was a there
was a point where it was like magic
Johnson that was a crazy time you know
since we're talking about AIDS because
that was doing that was there was an
AIDS pandemic yeah right I'm not sure if
it was obviously a global pandemic but
during that time wherever was like the
60s or the 70s or some [ __ ] like that it
was a huge [ __ ] thing yeah is like
somebody only told me it was like it was
almost like everybody was scared to have
sex at that point like nobody wanted to
have sex yeah yeah if I stuck my dick in
somebody like Eddie Murphy say like on
Raw my
[ __ ] what explode you know so I
wonder how they dealt with a [ __ ]
oh no no Magic Johnson had apparently
you know probably that in that quote
that I'm telling you about
he said unprotected hey so like it's
crazy that you know they would no matter
what city they would travel to on deck
they would have like 40 women at the
hotel lobby waiting to be serviced they
show time that's [ __ ] funny there
another like 40 notes from women like
perfume scented notes you know saying
that they will you know call me or Lea
you know I want to hang out well you
know DDM back in the exact and then so
like pregame postgame traveling on the
road like it was non-stop and then what
kind of a put a damper on it was one of
the the Lakers it was this
I forget what position he played I
forget his name even it was this white
dude but everybody he just had this
reputation of being as dumb as a rock
like he just was not a very bright guy
yeah he he just I guess told his wife of
what was going on you know and like what
what he was him and the team was
partaking in and then so that wife
called the other wives of play or she
went and and then the funny [ __ ] is
these other wives some of them was like
yeah okay what's what's going on like I
is one of those girls - yeah like it's
cool it's just one less [ __ ] I got a do
for them you know he's got knocked up
all smarter than those [ __ ] and then
other other wives are kind of like oh
you know I had a hunch and you know I'm
not too happy about it but what can you
do
exactly but it's a it's kind of crazy
how like that Showtime era did the
amount of fun and like other players to
on other teams and other celebrities
right apparently there was a this thing
called like the forum girls in the forum
parties right so at the forum they would
have these post game parties and like it
was basically known to be just riddled
with girls you know like man I this is
why because of stories like this yeah
it's very easy to believe all these me
to stories yeah yeah yeah right just
because I mean there's so many stories
about Bill Cosby you know I've said this
to ya the first 12 women that came out I
was like damn [ __ ] is lying but once
once lady 800-900 that part though right
because for me his legacy and what Bill
Cosby did for me like made me not want
to hear these stories I personally just
didn't want to believe that somebody the
jell-o pudding guy yeah it was the guy
that really just didn't even use his
[ __ ] on other people cursing right yeah
there was a story that Eddie Murphy told
where Bill Cosby almost ended Eddie
Murphy's career because of how how much
he made him feel bad about their content
right was like he was cussing and all of
that right yeah this is not commie this
is not what you do yeah and it should
not wholesome enough yeah you know lo
and behold he's [ __ ] sporting his [ __ ]
it's not rape is raping women you know
like it's like he's just going to Sunday
service like he's supposed to do I think
I think that's kind of like the fine
line between you know celebrities who
over flex their power and celebrities
who just kind of like skirted it a
little bit you know it's like cuz there
is a thing too with Magic Johnson's
house parties it was like notorious
right everybody wanted to come to these
parties because they knew it was just
like an orgy filled party like by
midnight it was like a rule everybody
had to have been getting it on by men if
you're not getting it on you are banned
from ever coming to this market room
must have smelled like ball sack and
[ __ ] actually must have been disgusting
somebody doing
[Laughter]
it's definitely puss I could tell no but
then like the story is is that all the
women who were invited to this party it
was like a foregone conclusion that they
were down like if you weren't if you
stepped in this is what's right if
you're coming here then this is what's
happening here right it's already
understood and if by an off chance
you're not getting it on by midnight
then Magic Johnson is gonna personally
come to you and let you know
no no not [ __ ] he would personally
come to you and let you know like it's
time to be getting it on and if you're
not gonna do that then you can leave and
you're never gonna be invited to this
party so like that's kind of like the
fun he's not getting rapey he's just
letting you know like if you're not down
with this if it's not consensual sex
going on by midnight
you gotta get you can be anywhere but
here you gotta hit no I got it was like
that man the whole age thing makes sense
it's like boy it's like that if the fact
that he only has with alright the math
was like two thousand something women
are you're [ __ ] crazy
a year you know and it would fall off at
that point now leprosy on that [ __ ] he
he had the energy broke cuz he like this
was like I said pregame postgame massive
yeah like this like insatiable appetite
yeah he's like six to twelve women with
it [ __ ] sex is tiring sometimes
is so exhausting I used to go out this
one girl who find you like well I think
a lot of the times you know guys joke
about the [ __ ] a lot right maybe I'm
just not the average human being yeah
but they're like yo like I want a girl
that wants to [ __ ] all the time I'm down
with it that's what you think you know
people who say that [ __ ] people don't
got jobs
all right you jobless [ __ ] I
don't know how Magic Johnson did that
[ __ ] but I'm somebody knows his libido
was on the loose
with playing ball if you go if you
played like slow-mo sometimes all get
his dick is hard that's how this will
had like the best [ __ ] swats that
ever this will swatted balls with his
dick that and but that's just so crazy
to me that like he was having you know
sex of multiple women before the games
and he still played like that like where
do you get the energy man like what the
possible Lud is running through your
veins after I have sex dude I'm a mobile
you could rob me at that point I would
do nothing exactly well that's the whole
point of the orgasm is just I'm [ __ ]
done melody that would help him [ __ ]
perform a [ __ ] yeah that's my parent its
I guess it's like you know one of those
people that that small group of people
where they get high and they're
productive they're actually productive
when they're high you know
let's never look at Michael [ __ ]
magic Johnson the same way ever again
thanks to you alright you want me to
ruin another player not that it's
somebody that you all said oh no not
Kobe not Kobe Karl Malone you know the
mailman the mailman delivering dick
everywhere no I mean worse than just
delivering dick you know this dude got a
[ __ ] thirteen-year-old girl pregnant
you know that he has a kid from this
thirteen-year-old girl
it was when he was in I think high
school you know and he was like this
local star right 36 9 he [ __ ] at 13
diccon she didn't [ __ ] that girl
apparently I'm sorry's and and the
parents of that girl didn't want to
press charges because they didn't want
to be the one responsible toting his
career right cuz he was a local hero
everybody loved him you know it was like
a small town like a farm town he knows
for the black community we all have to
take this one and and like he he like
denied you know this responsibility for
the child this this eight-foot child is
not much the jobs buck is six seven
years old mister kid and then you know
he impregnated another girl nice
[ __ ] got in
you know I think and is still in his
teens too and then he had twins the
players cars did yeah and I was like yo
man this that was straight-up break arm
alone [ __ ] [ __ ] a 13 year old girl
there buyin had a kid not just raped her
got her pregnant and [ __ ] you know I
talked about the whole Takashi 690 [ __ ]
right now you know a little snitch yeah
because there was a there was a court
case on him because in in a music video
or a video or something he had a 13 year
old girl in there one of his home he's
like they were kind of running a train
on her I guess he was they're recording
right one I mean maybe not to those
exact specifics but he didn't [ __ ] the
girl yeah yeah and but he was he was
there yeah the girl was on his lap or
whatever yeah and I was making a point
that you know a 13 year old looks like a
[ __ ] 13 year old right in a story
right I don't give a [ __ ] right yeah
yeah and some of the comments are like
David you don't know 13 year old girls
now yeah no [ __ ] I don't know [ __ ] 13
no girls right now I'm a [ __ ] adult
but here's the thing though no matter
how much makeup you put on a 13 year old
girl when you're like 18 you know that
that thirteen year old girl is I
understand though like when they're like
16 17 18 right right then it's like if
they put their makeup on right yeah it's
kind of is ibly it might be sometimes
really hard to tell yeah but when they
open their [ __ ] mouth and they're
talking it's like that's a 13 year old
gray also to 13 like I said 13 year olds
smell like wet backpacks they they
[ __ ] stink like I know for a fact
they [ __ ] stink like I was a youth
minister at a church some of my kids
were 13 year olds yeah those
[ __ ] smell like [ __ ] yeah but
you know what man though the that they
do have a point with the comment because
like when you are out in public now and
you kind of see the standards that
teenagers have to meet almost the
standard of beauty the standard of what
it's like to be attractive right it's
like I mean I feel [ __ ] terrible for
them man
what we had that too I think now is just
because social media has has it so much
it's it's it's like I mean they
definitely look better than when we were
13 years old like definitely 30 nose
looked like 13 year olds yeah there
wasn't YouTube tutorials on how to do
your makeup how to dress or whatever it
but but it's like dude you're [ __ ] 13
like that's not what you should be
focusing on man 13 is just B 13 you have
fun you know revel in the fact that you
don't have real responsibilities yet you
know what I mean I don't want to do that
though they definitely here's here's one
of the most annoying things that I see
just for somebody who's like you know
I'm 32 now right here's here's a habit
that you guys should know if you're
younger older people know when you're
trying to act like you're way above your
age and it's the most [ __ ] annoying
thing on earth
no decent adult is gonna look at you and
be like well this 20 year old can speak
like me yeah 30 year old as a business
and right is life together right when
you do that stuff you come up very
disingenuous and we kind of just
entertain you we go okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then we move on I'm not saying
that you can't be mature for your age at
the age of 20 but when you try to act
like you're something that you're not
right when you're not 20 you are gonna
miss those you're gonna miss that age be
a 20 year old I'm not telling you to go
out there and get drunk and get smashing
you know do all that [ __ ] you should do
it but yeah if you don't want to that's
not your thing right but but when you're
that kid that always tries to act a
little older than you are it's really
[ __ ] I'm not sure for hate hearing
that [ __ ] when I go to these college
shows sometimes now and some of these
kids are very sweet right come up and
they're like yeah you know these kids
I'm like [ __ ] you are these days you
just trying to act like you're something
that you're not like these other dudes
that like I went to this one school
these [ __ ] the most
irresponsible little [ __ ] just getting
smashed I don't be dead all right but
the thing is that I'm like I'm not
saying that what they're doing is
amazing I'm just they're just being you
know a bunch of 20 year olds yeah that's
what's up yeah but this other kid
there's one specific here that I
remember he was like yeah I'm not trying
to be like them I'm trying to be
responsible my shits like cool story bro
shut the [ __ ] up I don't care like what
am I gonna fight you to my hotel so we
could have some coffee and talk about
life now yeah what you talking [ __ ]
about them that you doing normal [ __ ] if
you don't like you don't gotta like it
yeah it's that that that snob enos that
fakeness of like trying to be older than
you actually are
it doesn't help man just be you know I'm
sure for sure I mean look like he said
it's one thing to be like more mature
for your age but you know don't
try to act like you know more than you
actually but you know what I can't I
can't even say anything about that
because I was that kid too like we when
we were growing up as teenagers to thing
about it man like our parents would pass
on you know wise worldly experience
based advice to us and we'd be like nah
we know better or I know better yeah you
don't know what the [ __ ] you're talking
about so it's just I feel like kind of a
nature of like a maturing process of
always feeling like you know better and
then once you actually start to
understand and know you realize I didn't
know [ __ ] you know I think that what I'm
talking about is the kid that thinks
that they're the wise parent 20 you
think that you're the wise parent yeah
you want to give you know virtues of
wisdom at the age of 19 and 20 a psych
dog shut the [ __ ] up well I just have an
opinion that's completely fine right to
sit there and then tried it like I'm
like I'm mature I hate the [ __ ] the
most annoying girl so this is one girl
her name was oh don't don't
her name was James she went to my church
right Illinois the [ __ ] out of me and
the reason why is because she was dating
an older dude at our church uh-huh so
because she was dating the older dude
she was my age she assumed that she was
also the older person known
I've never gotten so entertained enough
[ __ ] in my life and at church I
remember this [ __ ] like our Bible study
teacher wasn't there and so you know
were like hey our Bible studies teacher
didn't show up he didn't let anybody
know mother I'm playing in hopes baby
and so I started you know we everybody
was leaving the class like oh they're
not coming through it like well guys
he's not here but today I've decided
that I'm gonna leave Bible study and I
looked at I was like the [ __ ] you're not
[ __ ] you're my age laughs yeah but she
always wanted to make it a point to make
sure that she everybody knew how much
how better she was and everybody I'm
dating a guy who is so much older see
and there's no there's no way an older
guy would date me yeah if I wasn't at
his maturity level you know this it's
it's that's like more of a superiority
complex and it just doesn't have to do
with age I mean it even has to do with
things like race right and like you know
a classic example of that is dating
outside the race because you feel like
your own race you feel ashamed or you
feel like is inferior in some way and
then so like you get this support
superiority complex by dating
like a white person for example right
and you kind of look down on you know
you guys I know I don't date Asians the
[ __ ] you talk about you don't date
Asians you're [ __ ] Asian right like
what do you what are you talking about
used to bother me how they it's like
what look if you want to be in an
interracial relationship that's all fine
and good like that [ __ ] on your own
calls exactly why do you got to look
down on your own [ __ ] people in your
own culture like that's who you are but
it's it's like almost a thing of like
what do you call that like transferring
prop then I forget that the term for it
but it's like because I have white dick
inside of me like that you're still a
little kooky huh everybody looks at you
they're just like oh you're that goofy
magnates that white guy and you mean
that you're white for the other women
too you know it's just a way yeah for
guys to you know I mean but yeah I've
definitely had experience what a handful
of people like that you know during my
life and it just always bothered me I I
never understood that to like when I
wonder what happened to that person as
an individual that made them say I will
never date a an Asian man or or an Asian
girl
yeah or you know I'm pretty sure they
have that like in their own races right
like I'm pretty sure there's like you
know black folk they're like I will
never date a black man or a black woman
yeah and I wonder what happens and what
was the trauma that you linked with that
in that situation that made you self
hate so [ __ ] right right because I
don't really understand that for me like
for example I didn't think that I would
end up with the Korean girl and I
happened to have right and it wasn't
because I hated my own culture because I
grew up in an area pedometer where there
wasn't a lot of cream right that's stuff
that I really found that attractive yeah
I had like culture wise I thought it was
so different but later on I found out
that you know being a Korean American
and being born in Korea speaking Korean
having Korean parents all the other
stuff clearly cuz I am Korean it was
important to me is something that's very
important to me yeah right yeah I didn't
so when I met Muriel and then we were
connecting on Korean [ __ ] I'm like oh
she I'm actually very happy that you're
Korean mm-hmm ya know yeah I mean that's
the thing is that look there's there's
nothing wrong
with dating inside of your race and
outside of your race it's like because
you know when you're kind of touching on
what you're what you're talking about is
just kind of being able to share that
culture maybe you want to pass that on
to your kids there's none so bad
yeah there's nothing wrong with that I
wanna teach my kids that you should beat
your kids when they've goddamn reason
and let them know that they got a
ass-whooping on layaway what you do you
know when you go spank your kids no I'm
not I'm not I would try my best not to
in the YouTube blogs I'm not gonna spank
them but you best believe that my
cameras I'm slapping that kid that's
something I've thought about a lot man
because it's like I'm gonna try my best
not to you know our parents their
generation the generation before that
before that I mean they they didn't have
like information and education that we
do today which is you know you look at
you look at the statistics
I mean negative reinforcement is shown
time and time again not to use exactly
as positive reinforcement right you know
what I found out too just from just from
like personal experience yeah like I
know certain I used to say this a lot
and I still kind of believe it sometimes
depending but just from the stuff that
I've seen in the past like 7 to 7 to 6
years right and within the seven years a
lot of my friends have had kids aside
from JK people their new parents I'm
talking about people before them yeah
but a lot of these parents too like they
used to say like oh I had a what my kids
because kids are very different like
they don't some kids just don't learn a
certain way yeah I'm like I I do believe
that to a certain extent right some kids
are just a little more problematic than
others everybody's a little bit
different right all animals are like
that but these parents that I've seen
that said that about these kids are
problematic and they have these bad
habits yeah I've seen what they do and
I'm like well of course they're bad
habits that you don't like is because
half the time you think is cute and you
let them get away with it you know
because sometimes it's funny to that
right oh that's cool but I'm a blah and
then they get upset later on when they
get older it had this bad habit it was
like was because you thought it was cute
when they were younger right and now
that they're older they think that it's
okay yeah cuz you were all like oh I
want them to be my best friend and you
chose not to be a parent first and then
you had this so it's not that the kids
fault yeah it wasn't problematic since
the jump it's just
you wanted to be a fun parent so you got
a fun kid that's all right you know if
you want a kid to be a little bit more
respectful and obedient than you have
this dance the thing is that what may be
fun to you like you have to have a
broader perspective on things and then
you got to understand like what you
might what you might find this funny or
cute or what everybody else yeah exactly
you have to be aware of that right and
so not just what kid but even something
like pet owners right yeah like dog
owners right oh it's fine
you know he's just he just likes he's
just happy to see what if that person
doesn't want the dog jumping on them
though dude you know play me something
right now when you bring mesh it up yeah
just [ __ ] four days ago
I don't wanted to tell this [ __ ] on a
podcast I'm so glad you brought this up
I have a really close friend that I know
right yeah I'm gonna say her name
because imma bring on the podcast
explain herself right I [ __ ] love
this girl to death like if she wasn't a
lesbian if I was single yeah or maybe if
I was a lesbian she'd probably be
somebody that I would probably have you
know met up something like that yeah if
I was if I was a lesbian female some
what happened right now so this girl
hilarious I find her so [ __ ] funny
yeah but she is the one of the best and
worst dog owners I've ever seen in my
life
best dog owner this says she really
cares about her dog yeah but the thing
that she doesn't understand as a dog
owner is that just because you find your
dog cute and you love it doesn't mean
that everybody else will write as she
wants people to love her dog so [ __ ]
much yeah so we're in the situation of
COBIT right now that some people are
very weird and weary about touching
other people's dogs yeah you don't want
to get turned on the dogs in turns over
to you whatever the case right I don't
know the science behind it but that's
just how people feel so she has his new
dog shoutout to Eunice I love you very
much but you laugh at the situation and
I was so irritated at her because I'm
taking her on my normal walks and you
know people know me in the neighborhood
as a chubby Asian guy that walks eight
miles a day you know this right yeah
it's pretty obvious so I'm walking
around and it's been so funny this new
puppy comes up and there's a there's a
family of not a family it's the mom and
the kid they're on a picnic blanket
outside right and her dog off the leash
starts roaming towards towards him right
yeah you could tell just by looking at
them she was a really little
uncomfortable right uncomfortable
because the kid likes dogs and wants to
pet it so bad but she already told him
not to it's verbally she goes no honey
you can't pet the dog and then as a dog
is walking closer and closer to the
family she's just like looking at her
dog not doing anything and I'm like hey
go get your dog right she goes no my dog
sweet it doesn't matter if your dog's
sweet they're not he won't bite ya okay
she doesn't give a [ __ ] that he doesn't
bite she doesn't want your dog near them
because the kid wants to pet the [ __ ]
dog the thing man and so this girl as
she's doing this right I'm literally
watching her and I'm sorry it wasn't off
that she didn't have a leash on the dog
right and I might bring your dog over
here right she was she goes okay it's
like oh my dog's really sweet she says
it again I'm like Eunice
they don't [ __ ] care they just don't
want their your dog near there get their
face at this comfort the mother looked I
mean it's not even a racist a the mother
just looked petrified like get your
[ __ ] dog away from me and she goes oh
I'm sorry now if you know that this
person doesn't want your dog near them
because of the whole social distancing
thing right which is something that they
verbally communicated what would you do
would you bring the dog towards you or
would you walk up to the person to grab
your dog right she goes over it gets
like [ __ ] a foot away from them and
picks up her dog and the lady's like
this yeah and I'm like [ __ ] you have no
nunchi whatsoever dude and as we're
walking I'm like what the [ __ ] was that
yeah
why didn't did you not see this late
this woman who was clearly uncomfortable
with you shoving your dog in their face
yeah she goes no my dog sweet I'm like a
[ __ ] I will choke you the [ __ ] out
that's not the point she's like why are
you mad at me I'm like I'm irritated at
you because now I'm known as the guy who
brought the psycho woman with her puppy
right before seeing it on these white
they're like leave them alone no that's
the thing is that I feel like you know
some of these pet look and there's
nothing wrong with loving your pets
that's all fine and good but don't be
oblivious to like how other people feel
because think about it what if in that
situation maybe that the mom or maybe
even the kid has a
drama maybe they got bit by a dog oh
yeah allergies are some [ __ ] right or
have allergy like you can't assume that
how you feel about your pet is the same
way that other people are gonna feel
about it and so like you know I see some
of these pet owners like who don't put
their dog on a leash
right and the dog is going wild running
up on people licking that's not
something they invited into their life
they didn't say let me let this Jah dog
jump on me and lick me and and [ __ ]
have them invade my personal space like
if people who own pets don't understand
that shame on something to do with how
sweet their dog is she just think that
everybody should love her dog the way
she like just gotta respect other
people's [ __ ] space and property his
goes so [ __ ] funny she treats her dog
almost like it's an actual like person
gentleman we're at a parades right she
goes hold on stop I gotta show my dog
this bridge she goes look it's a bridge
this is a bridge cards go under it this
is an overpass I'm like you [ __ ]
dumbass your dog doesn't give up the
bridge hearts their coin hundred
remember bridge bridge I have footage of
it I recorded it on my phone because of
how ridiculous it is like this lost her
[ __ ] mind yeah she's insane she's
becoming one of those dog people she
goes my dogs are so much smarter than
yours it's like no your dogs a regular
[ __ ] dog is a dog now you have
someone like some of those some of those
friends that you like videos of their
kids and like do my kids so smart and
it's like the most basic [ __ ] ever
taught my friends sent me a video
there's a kid showing colors yeah kids
[ __ ] - and he goes like do my kids so
smart yeah he knows the difference
between yellow blue and red like I told
him this block was red and it's like not
yellow I'm like dog your kid only did
that now he's to your kids [ __ ] dumb
it's like you might be slightly [ __ ]
those are people who are just out of
touch with reality man like it's not
grounded and it's like I don't I'm sorry
I said the R word apologies I had to put
that out there
apologies I keep forgetting I'm learning
I'm learning well not if
you know the child is actually [ __ ]
though I don't think we're allowed to
say that all anymore I found that out so
I like I said I found out that you can't
use the word [ __ ] for anything for
even inanimate objects because I thought
[ __ ] was an adjective that you could
use for anything like if something is
malfunctioning is like it has like a
retardation right right but that word is
so sensitive you can't even use it for
like inanimate objects even though it's
not referencing a person people get mad
right right I mean like so that I know
it became much more like culturally
sensitive I guess a pop culture right to
use that but what if there's like the
the the child actually has mental
retardation blunted or so I don't know
because I don't I don't have anybody in
my family that I know has who has who's
of a [ __ ] [ __ ] so I don't know would
be what the proper term is but I know
it's not [ __ ] though it's like it's
like a man
mentally mentally challenged I mean I
don't know I don't know what it is but
the probably not the word to use yeah
nah bro I mean look man one time when I
was a young kid in Korea right I was out
in the countryside cuz that's where my
mom's family's from and you know we're
talking about farms and then they're
kind of behind the times right in terms
of technology and everything just a very
slow pace of life I saw this cow and it
was just right there so I was like I've
never [ __ ] seen a cow in real life
before I went up to the cow and I
started petting it oh good cow right and
this guy [ __ ] I don't know where
start [ __ ] scared the [ __ ] [ __ ] I so
I thought it he owned the cow right and
then he was mad that I was touching his
cow but then I realized he was not
saying anything it was just noises
coming out as of mouth I was like scared
I was like bro ten years old or
something right scared the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of me right I [ __ ] ran I booked
it I [ __ ] ran to my grandparents
house and I told him like dude this dude
just [ __ ] ran up on me and started
like making noises and yelling at me I
was just petting a cow and then they
they like what'd he look like and I
described to know he had a ball
it's like oh that's just too cheeky
right that was his name like he's
probably a little are worded like oh
he's just the local [ __ ] has already
known that he suffered from mental
retardation you know or he was I'm sorry
if that's not politically correct he was
mentally challenged yeah and he just
[ __ ] roamed the streets doing
whatever you know and solid [ __ ] yeah
it's it's like literally a village over
there and and like people just already
knew so they're just like oh that's just
too cheeky you know that's just too
cheeky being too chic like a country
bumpkin
oh okay and like you know at the time
like I couldn't really grasp it but I
was like I kind of understood on some
level he he just had something wrong
with him so when I saw him again fear
turned into just kind of writing him off
now like are you just crazy yeah cuz
yeah he did that [ __ ] again he started
like making noises at me and I was just
kind of like alright you know like it's
just what it is what it is but yeah I do
know that people have become much more
sensitive to it and I'm not being
insensitive to it I'm just kind of
referencing it from a cultural
standpoint where we grew up in the 90s
and and people just kind of used the
word [ __ ]
that's hearted for a lot and it wasn't
saying it in like a negative way like oh
you're a mentally challenged person
she's like that's dumb yeah it's just
it's just dumb just just like you know
how using gay for things became much
more sensitive to right time to change
the lot man
and I was really trying to keep up like
I said if I slip up every now and then
yeah I know was like I said I didn't
know about that until this podcast
people I know you can't use that for
anything now like people just take you
the wrong way right I understand like
it's not from a world that I come
because I don't I sound like I have a
child right was mentally right it's a
handicap mentally mentally challenged or
something yeah so it you know obviously
it doesn't sting personal
yeah so I get it yeah like god that's
completely that's the thing like I
respect it you know what it's called
people to sheiks nothing did yeah no but
yeah I I definitely am and in it that
kind of ties into the whole dog owner
thing it is being aware of like how it
might come across as somebody else right
and then so I got to be respectful of
that like yeah I come from a time where
we just kind of used it passively
without even thinking about it and it
wasn't necessarily like such a strong
derogatory word it was just such a
common word yeah yeah yeah
but then once it started getting to a
point where you know it started becoming
more offensive to people then it's like
okay I got to be aware of that and I got
to respect that you know and if a
certain group of people or just people
in general are taking offense to it and
that's fine like I wonder when I'm
always like in this weird place with
when it comes to saying offensive stuff
and it comes to comedy right because
comedy is such a weird space because
yeah I feel like if it's for the laugh
and the joke is executed right you could
say whatever right ever you want right
migrating Chappelle he did that yeah
yeah I saw that when he's talking about
it in his stand-up right yeah you know
Dave Chappelle talks about that stuff
and it's just I I feel like in the guy's
a comedy we can lose a lot of things if
I don't find it funny I'm allowed to not
find it funny yeah but I don't think
people should be canceled for it per se
right right even with that guy Shane
Gillis when he did that he he was that
comic that was supposed to be hired on
SNL and he was talking about how Asian
people are disgusting or something like
that right the reason why I found it
highly offensive I was kind of irritated
was because it wasn't a joke it was just
him saying that his [ __ ] Asian people
are disgusting right right there was no
bit yeah yeah yeah you know other comics
disagreed some some complex your ogen
said that he thought it was a bit and I
was like nah Rogan you off on this one
that wasn't a bit like I know what a
joke is that's not that wasn't a joke he
was just being an [ __ ] right
specifically not him it was like I think
that's his brother or some [ __ ] was
being kind of weird with it but then
people are like yeah he should be
cancelled for it I'm like I don't know
about cancelled like I'm allowed to be
upset about I'm a lot the flaming for
that [ __ ] should you cancel them the
human side
or the the the you know the millennial
persons kind of like maybe he should but
the comic sides of me like oh but that's
the thing though man is like people are
so [ __ ] sensitive now you know what I
mean like we're in cancel culture right
you get cancelled for anything and
everything and so like people are such
are so kind of afraid I guess to do
certain things say certain things and
look man it's like we're human beings
your allotted mistakes you know what I
mean you can make mistakes as long as
you own up to it you recognize it and
you improve on it right like alright if
you're if you're [ __ ] raping people
over and over again
that's just that's a whole nother thing
but if you genuinely weren't aware or
just had like a lapse in judgment even
right and might have said something or
did something that was offensive and you
didn't realize it at the time but then
you realize oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] up and you
own up to it it's like dude people
should be allowed that opportunity that
that that's not something that's like a
privilege you know what I mean it's it's
something that we as human beings no
matter what your age race you know
generation like we're all gonna [ __ ] up
at some point but people like to act
like they're [ __ ] perfectly yeah
that's the [ __ ] problem is like oh
how [ __ ] dare you what [ __ ] you
don't make mistakes you know like I
[ __ ] made a mistake I'm sorry you
know what I mean if you're genuine about
it and you own up to it that's one thing
but then if you're not owning up to it
and being like oh no like what I said
was completely right Asian people are
disgusting [ __ ] they smell yeah
I stand by what I [ __ ] said [ __ ]
too chic so [ __ ] those damn Ching
chongs I mean then that's a different
story right then people have
little bit more I guess right to to get
riled up by that but yeah man like
people are gonna [ __ ] up and I guess
because of the technology culture that
we're in today it's just a lot more
magnified right yeah if people [ __ ] up
back in the day like it would really
have to be a statute of limitations on
what you [ __ ] up on and how much you
could forgive but you could dig up a lot
of [ __ ] in people's personal past that
you've done a lot of photo shoots for
sure so it's like you know how much can
you hold on to that person if they're
not doing it anymore
yeah like for example there's there's
this guy a part of this channel called
eater I'm not sure if he's still doing
it now I forgot his name exactly but he
did something called the meat show and
he reviews a lot of place he's like one
of these dudes that are you know a
self-proclaimed expert or maybe he is an
actual expert does he ever beat the meat
though of course but this [ __ ]
he apparently compacted the day and I
laugh at this it's so funny but you know
you see him now doing reviews of
specific Steakhouse and he gets flamed
online because he uses like very very
hoity-toity words to describe me he goes
oh the meat has a has a cheese like funk
and it's ethereal and the this banana is
the spinalis d'Orsay and like you know
how he talks about food some people
sometimes people think is pretentious
yeah for me when I watched a couple of
his videos I don't think those
pretentious I think he just does a good
job at explaining food and I like it
everybody's just passionate maybe he's
just a [ __ ] about it maybe you have a
small binocular or you have a very tight
full of vocabulary your dictionary is
this small and you don't understand what
he's saying I understand that you dumb
like I don't understand what he was
saying at the time but I was like oh
that's just sound delicious yeah but he
back in the day used to be a skinhead
somebody found out that he used to be a
part of a skinhead rock band and he was
like a skinhead so he was a full-on
racist dude and he had like skinhead
tattoos and everything but you see him
now yeah and the the the chefs that he
reviews one of his close friends like
his Japanese chef like he has people he
eats foods of all different races of all
cultures loves different cultures now
and he expresses his love in a pre
Jason threw food in the meat that he
eats right yeah so I look at somebody
like that and he used some skin 20 years
ago I'm forgiving of that [ __ ] know for
sure like Oh 20 30 20 years ago he was
young and he had stupid thoughts and
ideas yeah he's not that person now
right we're moving on from that I don't
even need to bring that [ __ ] up exactly
right so I think there's like a statute
of limitations when it comes to somebody
[ __ ] up yeah it's not like he
expresses those things now
yeah his close friends are you know
Asian Mexican whatever yeah he lives in
a very culturally diverse area he is
culturally diverse he's eating a lot of
different foods he's shining light on a
lot of different peoples and different
cultures food so clearly he's not racist
now yeah and I don't know why people
feel like he had to take a hiatus for a
little bit too and I wasn't watching him
at this time but apparently he he took
like a year break or six seven month
break because people were upset of his
past but for me I'm like why you care so
much about his past now when right now
he's a good exactly man exists ain't
cancel culture man like people are up in
arms about oh this this person did this
yeah yeah good and it's like come on man
people [ __ ] up people make mistakes yeah
and sometimes those mistakes are more
extreme than other mistakes but if you
learn from that and you moved on from it
don't [ __ ] bring it up like it's the
present you know what I mean yeah and
like a good example of that situation is
like American History X right great
[ __ ] movie by the way if you haven't
seen that movie definitely check that
out
oh that's the first time I learned about
curbing somebody curb stomping ya know
goes nick source in but yeah Mick
stellaris Nick stellaris okay yep he was
I mean look man was it wrong that he had
those type of ideals sure I mean does it
not give him the opportunity to improve
as a human being though oh absolutely
yeah and the fact that there are people
trying to deny him now of who he is and
was like no you were this yeah you
should be punished for that right I'm
sure this dude had his like interior
moral and ethical
right of like how he looked at life and
how he looked at a race apparently right
I'm sure he went through his own inner
turmoil yeah to get past that maybe
maybe he's even been punished in in some
ways right to have those type of views
and have that type of lifestyle so who
the [ __ ] are we then to like pass
judgment on people and be like nah man
you can't [ __ ] hide this [ __ ] you
deserve to be punished in the present
for you know if he committed a crime
like he killed somebody that's a
different story right like he was a
murder that wasn't convicted for us
right I might feel a certain way right
yeah [ __ ] but if it was just kind of
like hate crimes or he didn't do any
anything serious I'm reading this right
now so what he was he goes I was a
British kid who wound up falling in with
a group of white pride American
nationalists so he I guess he immigrated
to the United States when he was like a
teen I'm sure so he has like a New York
British accent it's a little weird it
comes in and out yeah and he goes I when
I was a part of this group I believe the
hateful things that they believed and
help spread the message I was the lead
singer of a popular hardcore band and
fed off and indeed contributed to the
darker impulses of this scene yeah I'm
ashamed by what these materials reveal
about my past but I'm proud to state
that clearly and unequivocally that I
condemn racism intolerance and bigotry I
could not work for a company like box
media which strives for culture of
diversity and inclusion or write about
the joyous world of food in New York if
my views were not diametrically opposed
to those I held back right I mean look
it's it's not even about what he says
it's about how he lives his life that's
the only thing you need to look is like
an example write it if this dude is
living his life in a way that it would
pretty much be impossible if he still
had those views and thoughts and ideas
but the dude is living his life let him
do him right like I agree now we're not
we're not in a place to [ __ ] pass
judgment for something you did as a
teenager oh my god a teen eight I did
stupid [ __ ] as a teenager right know for
sure you just do me [ __ ] yeah but like
if people you know if I was in a place
of like you know celebrity and people
were trying to dig up [ __ ] like that and
and [ __ ]
I don't know sabotage my character now
Who I am now know who I am now as a
result it was a process it was a
learning process I did stupid things
made stupid mistakes right but the
important thing is that I learned from
it and I improved from it you know it's
not that I stayed in that same sometimes
do people confuse that that thing of you
know when people like us sometimes give
advice and we you know we say things
with a lot of like gusto all riled up
about [ __ ] it's not from a place of I
don't make mistakes it's like I just I
could see myself making those same
mistakes to a lot of those times too
when I give advices because I've already
made that mistake already yeah so it's
coming from a place of learning right so
it's it's a representation of what I've
done in the past and I'm only trying to
pass on wisdom or what I think is wisdom
anyways so you don't make the same
mistakes that I do right right that's
all that it is it's not it's not it's
not from a point of me saying that I'm
perfect
yeah you know no I mean I give like a
personal anecdote from my life where it
has to do with race right like when I
was younger in elementary you know I
faced a lot of racism primarily from
white people white kids right and so I
started to develop this kind of like
real hatred for for white people like I
started to think all white people are
like that but that that was born out of
such a limited view of it you know it's
not that I had this diverse experience
of white people from all different play
it was like in a neighborhood or at
school or whatever like these white kids
were just constantly [ __ ] hating on
me right and I got into fights as a
result of that too
but what started to kind of turn it
around for me was that one of the
parents of those like group of white
kids who was basically saying racist
[ __ ] or whatever I mean to be honest -
it probably stem more from ignorance for
them yeah that rather than like actually
being racist right but that lady that
the mom of those kids was so [ __ ]
kind you know and like she would always
kind of go out of her way to like make
me feel welcome like even invite me to
their house but then it would feel weird
as [ __ ] cuz I'm like your kids are
hating on me but at the same time you're
you're so welcoming and inviting me over
telling me to lie sir
jump you dude bury me in the back yeah
no but like yeah she would like baked
like banana cake you know and like that
why people should be yeah yeah yeah that
started even even at that young age
started to open up my mind like oh it's
not just white people you know it's just
like the small group of [ __ ] kids who
are deciding to be the way that they are
because they don't understand maybe
because I'm so different from what they
eat different things from them I speak a
different language than them and then
from a place of like misunderstanding
you know and that's that's the hard part
when you're super angry and upset yes
kind of detaching yourself from that
situation and saying this is just a bad
instance because of this and I can't
judge that whole group as a whole cuz I
would hate for that to happen to our
culture too right so like even with the
with the the you people stuff right but
I didn't walk away from that situation
saying like I hate all white people
right all I said was I hate old white
women you guys are a [ __ ] no disguise
as a white woman with three to was in
her stroller what the [ __ ] did I could
Robert Downey moving in traffic yeah
Tropic Thunder would not survive in
today's climate man Tropic Thunder I did
I saw that the kind of the conversations
about that and I really wonder man I've
known man I think people will be up in
arms about that [ __ ] just because of how
I think if we did a Robert Downey jr.
almost win like a [ __ ] award for that
[ __ ] fight I don't know I don't know
but look man like hey that [ __ ] you have
commented on it and said look man that
[ __ ] was hilarious you know yeah because
I mean the Robert Downey jr. he's making
fun of these people these method actor
exactly exact thats the point that
people need to really look at is that
he's making fun of those method actors
who get so lost in their craft that they
think that they could be black in his
cool right exactly right it's it's a
lapse in judgment you know it's not it's
not stemming from a place of like
negativity you say they're there on your
side they're making fun of people right
people are [ __ ] dumb and it's done in
film and just in comedy that's what I'm
talking about with that line of comedy
you know how much can we police comedy
to a certain extent yeah if you don't
find it funny you don't have to find it
funny but the canceling part is the part
that I get I get a little weirded out
that canceling culture is a little it's
like a knee-jerk reaction yeah and you
know with with comics too when they kind
of work out their stuff because when I
used to do stand-up comedy pretty
consistently
I don't do it as consistently anymore
yeah but when I was really enjoying it
like you hear people bombed their sets
all the time and the next week when they
come into let's say we're doing a
similar set later on I'll hear their set
again I'm like oh it's different and
it's so much better yeah and then
working out these kinks you know they're
trying to push the envelope and then
sometimes when that envelope gets [ __ ]
it's a little too much they go back they
rework it to make it funny again right I
think Dave Chappelle does a great job
with that too like he says some [ __ ]
just to bring it up on it I think it's a
sticks and stones he did a joke about
abortion right and so when he's doing
this joke about abortion I think a lot
of people too if it wasn't if it wasn't
Dave Chappelle they wouldn't have let
him finish the joke and they wouldn't
have even heard of the joke right yeah
so when how he starts off there with
that abortion joke - he's basically
saying like I don't care about it either
way right he goes like he goes he goes
when it comes like the topic of abortion
and he kind of says something a little
disparaging right and then people get a
little quiet but it was leading up to
the full joke where he's saying I don't
give a [ __ ] either way it's like you
could do it or you can't but it's up to
the woman to decide that [ __ ] because
it's their body they're a choice and the
joke that he was leaning on to that he's
saying he goes but I also believe if
you're a woman you want to keep it I
don't got to pay [ __ ] for a my wallet my
choice somebody in the middle of that
set got [ __ ] upset and they cut out
that joke right all they heard was him
saying like I don't get I think abortion
is wrong yeah yeah yeah but that was him
that was the that was the setup of the
joke to bring it up to that yeah but if
somebody cut him up because they were
upset and they started booing him
offstage you wouldn't have got to hear
the
we [ __ ] up the set right and that's
what I get worried about too that's one
of the bigger reasons why stand-up
comedy for me
started getting a little boring people
weren't setting up jokes right because
they're afraid of they're afraid of
backlash you're not saying good [ __ ] and
then on the other end because a lot of
people aren't making great comic jokes
down there and they're teetering on the
line of not being offensive there's
people who go too far this way where
it's just not funny and they're just
saying [ __ ] [ __ ] so there's nobody
doing both and pouncing out to make it
[ __ ] funny so now we have [ __ ]
comedians right here that are just
saying [ __ ] uh what was the what's
the word that I'm looking for when you
call that [ __ ] it's a phrase where
people would just say stuff to incite
anger or some [ __ ] like that or incite
like just doing like really outlandish
jokes yeah yeah and then you have other
people on this side that are just doing
too many PC Joe speakers they're afraid
to say anything right and it's the most
obnoxious thing on earth like have you
heard of stand-up people go hey so like
first of all you know [ __ ] this whole
coma thing I'm not races against Asians
I like black people - it's like bro just
say the joke right I want to set it up
where you make sure people know by the
way yeah by the way it's like the jokes
already bad now just [ __ ] say that
you're ready because you want to be on
everybody's side like I want to hear the
joke I want to hear your point of view
and you know comedy sometimes gets it's
it gets a little watered down though I I
mean yeah and Dave Chappelle touches on
that right of like how how sensitive
people are how brittle their spirits are
right but I mean comedy is essentially
social commentary right like if you
can't joke and laugh about what's going
on in the world right and and like I
think an interesting point that Dave
Chappelle made - is that there's always
somebody who's on your side whether
you're a year of [ __ ] you know
skinhead Nazi or or you're a liberal
like there's somebody who is always on
your side but at the end of the day
we're just comedians right and there's
there's like different ways of how
they're gonna execute their comedy right
but he was kind of making a point of
like even within the comedy world there
are people who are straight [ __ ]
racist you know but we don't really go
too deep into that right it's just like
we're gonna talk about what we're gonna
talk about it's meant for us to laugh at
and kind of
look at it in a different perspective
and just leave it at that that's what I
miss Patrice O'Neal man rest in peace
dude Patrice O'Neal he said something so
profound to me that especially you know
during the time for me now now I I'm
giving less [ __ ] again when I first
started in this space I could give a
[ __ ] list when anybody thought I said
whatever yeah but as people started
getting more sensitive I started you
know pulling back a lot of these jokes I
mean in my stand-up started becoming
really weak yeah I'm afraid I was gonna
offend people right but Patrice O'Neal
said it the best he goes when you do
stand-up comedy and you're doing this
set half the room should be cracking the
[ __ ] up and half the room should be
mortified right right because you're
saying something right you're not there
to get people on your side you're just
there to make somebody laugh and you
know make some social commentary and
that's really what it is yeah and that's
why I stopped doing stuff where people
like yo do you think this comic is trash
or whatever sometimes I feel that way
but other than other times too I could
look at I could look at people set now
and even like film books that I read and
you know just to go back to stand-up now
I could say I could see why that's funny
I don't the find it funny I don't have
to say that it's trash yeah for example
Dane Cook never laughed at a single
thing he's ever said yeah just because
with his jokes I could complete his
jokes before he before he says it you're
right
don't you hate it when you're a parking
lot and then your car screeches and he
goes I'm like what were you saying here
and what right but there's a reason why
he was selling out stadiums why he sold
out Madison Square Garden people find
him funny yeah just cuz I don't find it
funny it's not my cup of tea doesn't
mean that he's not killing funny I don't
find it funny that's all yeah and I
think that's true for everything not
just comedy right it's closing fashion
yeah I mean it has to be polarizing on
some level like you you really want to
draw a hate it or love it response
because if you get something in the
middle of like yeah it's cool then it's
forgettable polarizing art is the best
art man absolutely absolutely can Kanye
West dude yeah yeah I mean because it's
I mean to it to a degree you're trying
to stay true to yourself and like have
your craft reflect that right and
sometimes it might miss the mark in
terms of like it not being popular on a
wide scale right but at the same time
like you for whatever reason felt that
that's what you needed to express at
that point in time right yeah
maybe that's just where you are at in
life and you need to get that out of
your system to move on from it you know
whatever the case is but if you don't
draw that type of response from people
where they feel so strongly about it of
like you know that should as dope as
[ __ ] or that [ __ ] is wack as [ __ ] then
most likely you're gonna be forgettable
and being forgettable in this day and
age is like I think the worst thing that
can happen to you because there's so
many different things vying for people's
attention you're getting bombarded
constantly on social media that's so
hard
isn't that so interesting though how I
think that because of the space and how
much how much art is so readily
available yeah I think the one thing
that people are forgetting to its is
what are you saying when you create this
art and so a lot of a lot of the times
and this is how I say it anyways a lot
of people keep on putting out white tees
like this is what you're doing they go
oh I started a clothing brand I started
up this and that it's like cool thanks
for showing me your white tee I'm an
artist I drew this cool nice white
t-shirt mm-hmm that's why I see a lot
right people show me their music right
now and there's a lot of [ __ ] the music
that I don't really like that I don't
really [ __ ] with but I can see why it's
dope you know but sometimes when people
show me something oh I did this I'm like
cool nice white t-shirt mm-hmm it's not
anything you're not you're not doing
anything with this what you show me was
a blank canvas and anybody can put their
art to write your stuff isn't really
that special and people don't understand
it because they keep on trying to find
the norm yeah I think here's a great
example right so you know we started
that company secret society yeah I think
the really cool thing of what secret
society was doing comparatively to
comparatively to a lot of what other
people do the the designs that you saw a
secret society that you still see up up
now and is still running you don't see
other people that started up on the
YouTube space that is attached to a
brand like that period end of story
right there long tees their hoodies with
this little small little graphic on that
share secret society didn't have any are
freaking for our first line was all
[ __ ] hand crafts that she had doing
right
all that [ __ ] was custom spec the our
shirts were [ __ ] custom spec right
the way it looked the way design and our
just basic white tees you know what I
mean like that's not some [ __ ] that we
we got a blank of and and then we just
slap something on there
everything was cut and so everything was
r-spec and we went through rounds and
rounds of sample to make sure that it
was right before we went into production
for it you know and and and so like you
know here's the thing like when we talk
about something like art which is so
subjective right even like the clothing
line secret society right there are
people who are gonna look at and be like
yo that's wack and that's fine yeah
that's completely fine yeah that's fine
I would rather have that response that
you say yo this [ __ ] is wack then you
say that's cool you know I would much
rather have that response and then so
it's like within that even let's say for
me example I'm looking at somebody
else's [ __ ] whether it be music whether
it be clothes or whatever and I'm
thinking that [ __ ] is wack I could say
that but in the same breath be like but
I respect it you know because I'm also
where maybe that's not something that I
would want to do let's say let's take
music for example I find this rapper to
be wack as [ __ ] it's just not a style of
music that I would want to do right but
then also realizing that's not something
that I can do even if I wanted to do it
right and because of that I respect that
you know and and there is a space for
that and there are obviously people who
are gravitating towards it and consuming
it and that's one that's an important
thing too it's like you can't just you
can't just be dismissive of like that's
wack and as a result I think this person
has no creativity and and no right to do
whatever he or she is doing so I thank
you little yachty you know when I saw
his stuff I [ __ ] hated it at first
like it's easy to dismiss it right and I
was very dismissive of it I feel like
his music period I'm yeah but at the
same time I could see why people did
like it like I think like it spoke for a
generation that's not my generation yeah
these kids didn't care about lyricism
they didn't care about a dope beat they
just want to have somebody just rap
stupid [ __ ] and that's what they vied
with still think it's [ __ ] dumb but I
understand why it was successful yeah so
like being also like not being
dismissive of somebody's art because art
once again is very subjective yeah it
kind of brings introspection into your
art right like what you what you're
doing right you can't I mentioned this
before too like in order to
be an artist too which is something that
I always struggle with you have to be a
consumer of art too period end of story
if you're not consuming art on a daily
basis how can you create art right how
how is that possible like I see a lot of
people think I want to do music right
I'm like cool who are your favorite
artists what do you what's the [ __ ] that
you like listening to you don't have an
answer yes I so you don't consume art
but you talk [ __ ] about other people's
art how does it make sense right right
how how do you do that yeah I mean and
look like basically you have to be a
student of your craft first Yeah right
to understand okay these are the people
who came before you these are the people
that were great and they were great for
these reasons and to understand that
right I mean I had a moment when I was
working on my first mixtape where I
actually kind of quarantined myself for
music because I didn't want to be
influenced by what was popular in by
artists that I liked but at the same
time that doesn't mean that I didn't
study you know prior to that of all that
because you have to emulate in order to
find yourself right you start emulating
what the greats did like who your
favorite rapper was and I started
emulating those guys and then from
within that I start to find out my own
kind of things that I want to write
about things I want to structure how I
want to structure my rhymes right the
type of beats that I want to explore you
know and then from that you start to
kind of build yourself but if you have
no knowledge of your craft and you have
and you didn't study it at all then how
can you know like what was good and what
was bad before you you know it comes
from that perspective a lot of the times
too like we want to be we want to be a
critic first right and it's it's easy to
be a critic down you can be a Yelp
person easy yeah you can hate yell
people so much with everything that I
have to Yelp is such a blessing and also
such a curse I see all these people too
who are critics they talk about food
technique how things should be cooked
when they've never picked up a pen in
their life and their food [ __ ] sucks
right I hate that [ __ ] so much because
cooking is also an art yeah absolutely
you know yeah and so like don't be a
critic if you know if you haven't walked
the walk yet either right it's it's easy
to be a critic easy for us to sit there
and judge what somebody else does but
when you haven't walked like when we
have your walk in their shoes you really
don't know what's going on but that's
the thing though it's like the
technology caters to that right like pre
yelp you know
like would you have the balls to go up
to the [ __ ] you know restaurant owner
or to the head chef and be like yo your
food [ __ ] sucks
and I'll tell you why for these reasons
because it wasn't cooked well and you
did Disney no right but then when you're
and just some random anonymous person
you know on the internet who can
basically write things without
repercussions without even realizing how
much it might hurt this business
that's why Jonathan gold was a [ __ ]
Saint man he he said he would never
write negative reviews because he
understood like the power that he had
and his job yeah his job wouldn't be to
like criticize restaurants because his
thinking was if they are that bad then
they're gonna fail on their own anyway
well I a hundred percent agree when I
listen I'm only saying this because you
[ __ ] up Yelpers no it's me no I when I
this is prior to YouTube like Yelp was
around or maybe I was on YouTube at that
point but I don't really care and I
didn't really publish the fact that I
had a Yelp or anything right but when I
didn't like food I kind of rated these
restaurants based on what I thought
mm-hmm
what I thought the food was about yeah
but at a certain point this is before I
even owned a restaurant I was like I'm
[ __ ] up somebody's living mm-hmm you
know I started taking on that personal
responsibility of like you know what if
this foods not good
the this restaurant is not gonna last
yeah I don't have to go out of my way to
give them a one-star because I hated the
way they're [ __ ] their their pet I
taste right leave it alone and I'm
writing this stuff up like Oh like this
is an authentic Pad Thai it's like what
the [ __ ] do you know David so yeah what
do you know about authentic pad thai you
fat Korean [ __ ] like what are you saying
you're judging judging this person about
what their pad thai should taste like
maybe that's just how they like to make
it and you don't like it yeah it is what
it is yeah I do understand the opening
of uh allowing us to find places that we
like and dislike so we don't make those
same mistake right which is kind of cool
but sometimes when people go on these
reviews they [ __ ] destroy them yeah
and it's like why did you have to go out
your way to do that you know it wasn't
there was no
I do give one-star reviews but these if
I give you a one-star review it means I
absolutely [ __ ] hate you that you did
something funding to me are beyond the
food service right right right
like they were actually offensive like
when I walked in you went hello yeah
they give four or five star reviews and
that's it yeah I mean I find that's the
thing I've probably written maybe like
two one-star reviews in my entirety of
like Yelp existing and and those were
very unique circumstances where like you
said it was beyond the food like yeah
I've had tons of places where the food
was not that good but like you said to
like it's not something that I
necessarily have to write about my
standpoint if weif days if their food is
dis consistently bad then they're
probably gonna fail on their own you
know and that's why I really respect the
Jonathan gold somebody who saw such a
big and respected food critic like he
could easily destroy a business hundred
result with one bad review but he
recognized that he had that power and
took responsibility for it and so he
kind of had the same mindset that was
our honorary Asian dude so much if you
guys don't know who Jonathan golden
library well we're now food critic and
the thing that he did really really well
rest in peace was that he decided to
give people certainly he gave street
food prestige right yeah yeah he gave
food that a lot of people didn't think
deserve that type of respect because the
food that people kind of revered were
fancy a restaurants right like you had
the the fought the foie gras right the
caviar and also the stuff with these
really high expensive highfalutin
ingredients yeah
Jonathan gold would go to places that
were like Sichuan noodles all right
right he would go to places like you
know mariscos Jalisco right yeah like
the the Jalisco tacos Dorados right
which was a street trek right they did
they did um seafood like money's goes
right yeah and he would give him his his
rating of for the Jonathan gold star
yeah right
who started sending up a standard of
that great food they didn't have to come
from a fancy restaurant right there's
great food right under your [ __ ] nose
this whole time that other people local
eats they knew how amazing the stuff was
yeah that's why Jonathan gold to me was
the golden standard of what food should
be yeah
ate food he didn't say how it would make
him look he said how does it taste
yeah and that's all he cared about yeah
if it tasted amazing you got that gold
standard and you know it popped off ya
know for sure and like he kind of
brought in the horizons to of like
ethnic foods you know a lot of dude I
think food was a [ __ ] I appreciate that
guys yeah yeah and then some people you
know capitalize on it like there's a I
won't say it by name but there's a joint
where Jonathan gold really likes their
chili cheese fries and you know things
like that it's just kind of hole in the
wall fast-food place and then after they
got kind of the the Jonathan gold
approval they ramped up their prices
like two hundred pursue what is it [ __ ]
now that you put me on the spot blinking
up it's uh it's it's it's in a like
mid-wilshire area on on Pico [ __ ] what
was the name of this place now
have I been there before no you haven't
yeah and and I tried it and I'm like
this is good but you guys are charging
me like ten dollars for chili cheese
fries right now you know no there's no
is it they hiked up the price it's based
on inflation I'm more surprised about
how [ __ ] expensive Carl's jr. is now
oh I have a minnow condo in a hot minute
Carl's jr. to buy a meal now it's like
twelve bucks
they're six dollar burger is over six
dollars now really yeah it's not the
whole point of the six dollar burger
Carl's jr. was that it was under six
dollars it's over six dollars now do I
Carl's jr. is not cheap to eat at no
more twelve thirteen bucks man and the
thing is I remember uh like this was I
think about three or four years ago yeah
I went to college junior late at night
because I was just craving their spicy
chicken I looked at the menu I'm like
whoa this place is [ __ ] expensive
I guess because this place is 24 hours
they have to make their costs higher
right and then and then I went to
another Carl's jr. like a year later and
then like prices were still high and
then I talked to somebody about it and
they're like yeah Carl's you and your
prices are high now when the [ __ ] that
this happened and the only good for
their [ __ ] Chris cut fries man
first cut there Chris cut fries is my
[ __ ] bro I love their Crisco I don't
know what when you said cause do you
know I just got reminded of this clip
that's on Twitter of to crack heads
blown crack smoking each other's asses
[Applause]
super fancy and [ __ ] like on the fast
food yeah but for some reason when you
said that I just remembered this Twitter
video where I saw to crack kids blowing
crack up each other's asses I'll show
you that [ __ ] later that [ __ ] was
hilarious dude these [ __ ]
literally bent over his mother took a
hit of a crack pipe is it hey blew that
crack smoke into an [ __ ] and that
will turn around took a hit of the pipe
that will bent over and he blew the
phone oh my god I mean you note ordered
entertains me sometimes and it
infuriates me sometimes you know oh for
sure yeah because I see the kind of
stupidity that's on there and I'm just
like [ __ ] hell man Wow but let me
tell you something watching somebody
blow crack smoking somebody's [ __ ]
that's one of the best things I've ever
seen in my life I want to see that crazy
stuff people hug cracker dude like you
saw the guy that did a backflip off a
building like a like a two-story house
oh here's a back flip and lands like
straight on his face or his back he just
gets up and walks away
he bought crack on our amazing dude I
mean yeah yeah because they [ __ ]
become superhuman yeah you see that dude
that was walking around like a skunk or
[ __ ] like a mama [ __ ]
some people enrich their lives with
knowledge I look at videos of crackheads
dude that shit's [ __ ] amazing I mean
I trust me I've looked at some pretty
foul [ __ ] like my tolerance for foul
[ __ ] is pretty high and I'm talking
about like even morbid [ __ ] alright if
you guys want to test yourself of like
how much you can handle run the gauntlet
calm
that is what yeah is that like calm no
it's like it's so basically it's a
series of videos right
it's like stemming from all different
kinds of
but it just gets worse and worse and
worse I can't you know [ __ ] it like like
there's a clip of a girl eating smegma
oh I didn't create this sight bro I've
just been made aware of this site you
know usually some ad site dude I know
what's it called two girls one cup yeah
something like that no but that that's
just one example of it there's other
[ __ ] like a guy jumps off and then he he
barely misses going into the water hits
his face on like the edge it's like just
it gets and you see what his face looks
like you know did you see that clip of
that dude he's talking into the camera
mhm
I don't know what happened per se I'm
not sure if you saw the explosion no no
not the explosion I was hunting the bear
oh you got half his face ripped off
uh-huh and you see his eyeball hanging
out of the side she's talking in the
camera yeah yep probably like a shock
Hawking yeah to the [ __ ] phone
telling everybody what happened as as
his dead bears laying next to him but
the bear mauled half his face soccer and
then you see a photo of a map that and
they reconstructed his face pretty yeah
yeah face he was probably in such shock
that he didn't you know he didn't know
what to do he lost one of his eye but he
still has the other one that's lucky man
but yeah there's a lot of crazy [ __ ] on
the internet that's one how did you even
come by that website dude I don't even
remember man I think like somebody took
because you know there are people that I
meet once in a while where you know the
it's they're kind of the same breed
their tolerance for like fouls [ __ ] is
pretty high you know and then we'll talk
about oh did you see this clip did you
say I think it came from something like
that and they're like have you ever seen
one the gauntlet calm I you know what
now that I think about it maybe it was
one of my friends I don't know whose
tushy
this Korean fob yeah well guys this
wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast you guys have catch us on
all audio platforms we're a comedy
podcast about [ __ ] just to keep you
guys company on your every day commute
during Covey's but if it's not your
commute it's just you guys daagon off
and listen to [ __ ] and you listen to
this podcast and guys support this man I
don't know why [ __ ] YouTube is not
letting him monetize man there's some
[ __ ] like this dude is doing this
from the goodness of his heart creating
content for you run the gauntlet back up
yeah true she can run the gauntlet you
know but I have a patreon so the reason
why we have this new podcast off is
because the patreon people so they've
been you guys are paying the rent for
this place so thank you very much
they've told me how much money he put
into this place how much time he put
into this place support this man ya
realize a lot of smegma for this money
spent you know so yeah but thank you
guys for supporting us on the patreon
man without you guys yeah stuff like
this doesn't happen so I'm glad you guys
are liking the free content and this is
this is this is what it is man preciate
y'all so you could catch Edie Edie too
on Instagram if you guys want to check
out secret society go check that [ __ ]
out scrt by the way it's not spelled the
form word secret scrt society com same
handle for Instagram Twitter all of that
so find this check us out tell us
whether you love it or hate it we'll
take both of it with open arms
I don't know if I can kill you
[Laughter]